don't touch it don't touch me man I
don't usually wear this I next this from
the photo shoot because it's very
strange
I've always wanted to be a professional
footballer because it's physical and you
didn't get to do nothing but walk out
and take care of yourself and eat well
and and I can't I got to do all that and
that was that was quite good fun but
after about a month of that you stopped
to eat like you wouldn't believe and can
the football player inside of you in the
14 year old boy say interview this one
it's kind of in a coma and the adults
left they're going why have you done to
me I just had to work out to be able to
perform because it was just I wouldn't
be able to otherwise you know Michael
Clinton I thought was an incredibly
powerful and subtle film Israel I think
it cleared us the audience with
intelligence I thought everybody was
blown
the whole part leasing thing I don't
know what I stay away from that kind of
stuff generally every now and again I go
out and have a big old night out but and
I enjoy it but I generally just keep
quiet to myself this morning which
people in London and then there's more
New Yorkers in New York let's can I find
that quite
that's fairly typical of my experience
of Basel I might be talking through my
ass